FOLLOWED HIM OUT THERE.
MIKE.
>> Mike: MARK MEREDITH LIVE IN
WASHINGTON, THANKS A LOT.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THE
ELECTION AND THE ECONOMY WITH
THE TOP REPUBLICAN IN THE HOUSE,
KEVIN McCARTHY JOINS US LIVE
FROM BAKERSFIELD, CALIFORNIA, .
LEADER McCARTHY, IT'S GREAT TO
HAVE YOU.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON, I
APPRECIATE IT.
>> Mike: YOUR OBSERVATION OF
HOW VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
HANDLED HIS ATTACKS AND THE
SURGE OF YOUR CALIFORNIA
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS?
>> I DON'T THINK JOE BIDEN IS
GOING TO BECOME THE NOMINEE.
NOT FOR THIS POSITION, BUT FOR
MANY POSITIONS GOING FORWARD.
HE'S GOT A LONG HISTORY.
I THINK HIS TIMING IS WRONG AND
I THINK HE WILL NOT BE THE
NOMINEE.
I BELIEVE THERE WILL BE OTHERS
COME UP AND THERE WILL BE A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITY.
I THINK BERNIE SANDERS HAS THE
BEST CHANCE OF BECOMING THE
NOMINEE BECAUSE WHERE THIS
DEMOCRAT PARTY HAS MOVED.
IT'S NO LONGER THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY, IT'S BECOME THE SOCIALIST
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND
BERNIE SANDERS HAS THE BEST
PHILOSOPHY, BECAUSE HE WAS
REGISTERED A SOCIALIST WHO
REPRESENT THE CURRENT PARTY.
>> Mike: AS YOU TRAVEL THE
COUNTRY IN YOUR LEADERSHIP
POSITION INTERDISTRICT BACK HOME
IN CALIFORNIA, WHAT'S YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE STATE OF THE
U.S. ECONOMY?
>> YOU COULDN'T LOOK AT IT, WE
ARE THE STRONGEST WE'VE EVER
BEEN.
THIS MONTH ALONE, JUNE, THE BEST
WE'VE EVER HAD ON THE MARKET IN
80 YEARS.
UNEMPLOYMENT THAT CUTS ACROSS
ALL AGES, ALL DEMOGRAPHICS.
THE STRONGEST WE'VE EVER SEEN.
EVEN THE DEMOCRATS, IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT BLOOMBERG POLL JUST A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO, THE
SENTIMENT FOR THE ECONOMY IS THE
STRONGEST WITH DEMOCRATS SINCE
2001.
THAT'S STRONGER THAN ANY TIME
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS IN
OFFICE AND A LOT OF THAT CREDIT,
GOES TO THIS PRESIDENT.
IT REMEMBER WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
SAID, THE IDEA OF GETTING 3%
GROWTH, YOU NEED A MAGIC WAND.
ALL WE REALLY NEEDED WAS
SOMEBODY IN OFFICE WHO
UNDERSTOOD HOW TO MAKE JOBS, HOW
TO MAKE AMERICA STRONGER AND
REALLY PUT AMERICA FIRST
REREGULATION, THROUGH TAX
REFORM, AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH, NOT EVEN TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT WHAT HE ACCOMPLISHED
LAST WEEK AT G20 AND OVER
NORTH KOREA.
THOSE ARE HISTORICAL TIMES, AND
I THINK THAT IS WHAT'S GOING TO
HELP PROPEL THIS PRESIDENT TO
REELECTION.
>> Mike: LET'S DO A LITTLE
MORE ON FOREIGN POLICY.
FIRST, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
HISTORIC MOMENT CROSSING INTO
NORTH KOREA.
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
AND SOME 2020 DEMS HAVE CALLED
IT A PHOTO OP.
ARE THEY WRONG ABOUT THAT?
>> THEY ARE REALLY WRONG ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE THINK FOR ONE
MOMENT, AND IF YOU STUDY
HISTORY, WE HAD A REAL CHALLENGE
WITH THE SOVIET UNION.
IF YOU HAD RONALD REAGAN PRESENT
AT THE TIME, TO TRAVEL TO THE
SOVIET UNION.
WHAT PRESIDENT REAGAN STEP AWAY
FROM THE NEGOTIATIONS IN ICELAND
WITH GORBACHEV BECAUSE IT WASN'T
GETTING EVERYTHING THAT WE
NEEDED, AND YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED AT THE END OF THE DAY?
THE BERLIN WALL COLLAPSED AND SO
TO THE SOVIET UNION.
COMPARE THAT TO TODAY'S
CHALLENGE WHERE YOU HAD
NORTH KOREA TESTING LONG-RANGE
NUCLEAR MISSILES.
THAT'S NO LONGER THE CASE.
YOU WOULD PRESIDENT TRUMP STEP
AWAY FROM THE TABLE IN VIETNAM
BECAUSE IT WASN'T AT THE RIGHT
SETTING, BUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE RESET THE
TERMS TO HAVE A NEGOTIATION.
NOW IN TWO TO THREE WEEKS WE
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZING NORTH KOREA.
WE ARE SAFER TODAY BASED ON WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN ABLE TO
DO AND BUILD AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT KIM JONG UN'S FACE, YOU SAW A
SMILE THERE.
YOU'VE GOT TO BUILD TRUST BEFORE
YOU COULD EVER GET TO AN
AGREEMENT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
PRESIDENT REAGAN DID WITH THE
SOVIET UNION AND GORBACHEV AND
YOU SAW THE RESULTS, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CORRECT IN
THIS AND HISTORY WILL PROVE
THAT.
A-DETERMINER >> Mike: ON,
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO IS
EXPRESSING SERIOUS CONCERN
TWEETING OVER THE WEEKEND "IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS AGREED TO
REVERSE RECENT SANCTIONS AGAINST
HUAWEI, HE HAS MADE A
CATASTROPHIC MISTAKE, THE THREAT
POSED BY THE COMPANY, NO ONE
WILL EVER AGAIN TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT.
>> I HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT
HUAWEI, BUT REMEMBER WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID, HE SAID HE WILL
DEAL WITH THAT AT THE END OF THE
NEGOTIATION.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
STRONG AGAINST HUAWEI.
WE KNOW THE CHALLENGE OF WHAT
THEY HAVE, THE NUMBER OF
BACKDOORS.
WE KNOW WHAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
DONE TALKING TO OUR ALLIES.
IF THEY BRING IN HUAWEI
PRODUCTS, WE CAN NO LONGER SHARE
WITH THEM INFORMATION BECAUSE IT
WILL GO DIRECTLY BACK TO CHINA.
REMEMBER WHAT CHINA DOES.
IF CHINA HAS TO HAVE THE
COMMUNIST PARTY IN EVERY
COMPANY.
THEIR GOVERNMENT PART-OWNED
HUAWEI.
THIS IS A REAL CONCERN FROM A
SECURITY ISSUE LONG TERM AND I
THINK WE GOT TO LET THIS
PRESIDENT -- HE UNDERSTANDS
THIS, I'VE TALKED TO HIM.
I EVEN TALK TO THE PRESIDENT
TODAY HE CALLED, TALKING ABOUT
THE BORDER.
I KNOW WHAT THIS PRESIDENT
STANDS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SECURITY OF THIS NATION AND HE
WILL STAND FIRM AGAINST HUAWEI.
>> Mike: BEFORE YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES LEFT ON YOUR PAST AND
A PACKAGE NEGOTIATED BY
DEMOCRATS, SENATOR PATRICK LAHEY
AND REPUBLICAN
SENATOR RICHARD SHELBY, BUT IT'S
APPEARS IT SEVERELY DIVIDED THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY WILL OVER MEMBER THAT WE
CATCH THEM UP LIKE ANIMALS,
RIPPED THEM AWAY FROM THEIR
PARENTS AND PROMPT THEM WITH
DRUGS TO MAKE THEM STOP CRYING
FOR THEIR MOTHERS.
NO AMOUNT OF APOLOGIES, NO
AMOUNT OF DEBATING IN THIS
CHAMBER WILL MAKE IT BETTER,
MADAM SPEAKER.
>> IT WILL NOT BE THE END OF
THIS DEBATE, IT WILL BE THE
BATTLE CRY.
IT WILL BE THE BATTLE CRY.
>> Mike: HOW BIG OF A PROBLEM
TO SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI HAVE ON
HER HANDS RIGHT NOW?
>> SHE HAS A SEVERE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IF YOU WATCH THIS
DEBATE, IT LASTED MORE THAN 58
DAYS SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP
REQUESTED SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
FOR THE AID ALONG THIS BORDER.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" RODE
TWO EDITORIALS ABOUT IT.
MEXICO SENT 15,000 TROOPS TO THE
SOUTHERN END OF THEIR BORDER.
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THERE'S A
CRISIS.
EVEN THE SENATE DEMOCRAT -- THE
SENATORS ON THE SENATE SIDE
UNDERSTAND IT, BUT NOT THE
HOUSE.
A BILL CAME OUT OF THE SENATE
84-8.
IF EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE LEADERS
IF EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE LEADERI
IF EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE LEADERP
ON THE SENATE SIDE VOTED FOR IT,
BUT NANCY PELOSI DID NOT WANT TO
BRING THAT UP.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE SHE BELIEVES IN OPEN
BORDERS.
IF SHE WANTED TO DENY ANYBODY
WORKING ALONG THE BORDER THAT
THEY COULD NOT HAVE OVERTIME.
IN A TIME WHERE YOU JUST HAD
144,000 APPREHENSIONS OF PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY CROSSING JUST LAST
MONTH, SOMETHING WE HAVE NOT
SEEN IN A DECADE, THIS IS WHEN I
TALK ABOUT THIS IS NOT THE SAME
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF THE PAST.
THIS IS A NEW SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND MANY OF THE
MEMBERS THERE CALL THEMSELVES
THAT, AND THEY ARE NEW LEADERS
OF THIS SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND THAT'S A
REAL CONCERN.
NOT ONLY DO THEY WANT TO HAVE
OPEN BORDERS, THEY WANT TO ALLOW
ILLEGALS TO EVEN VOTE.
WE HAD A VOTE ON THE FLOOR ABOUT
ILLEGALS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
TOUCHING BALANCE.
THEY VOTED THAT DOWN.
>> Mike: SORRY TO INTERRUPT
BUT CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ MADE A
PLAYDATE ON MY PRETTY EXPLOSIVE
ALLEGATION ABOUT FACILITIES OF
THE BORDER.
LET'S PLAY HER COMMENT AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO RESPOND.
>> THEY PUT THEM IN ROOMS WITH
NO RUNNING WATER, AND THESE
WOMEN WERE BEING TOLD BY
OFFICERS TO DRINK OUT OF THE
TOILET.
IF THEY WERE DRINKING WATER OUT
OF THE TOILET, AND THAT WAS THEM
KNOWING A CONGRESSIONAL VISIT
WAS COMING, THAT WAS THEM ON
THEIR BEST BEHAVIOR TELLING
PEOPLE TO DRINK OUT OF THE
TOILET.
>> Mike: WHAT YOU MAKE OF
THAT, SIR?
>> I WASN'T IN MY.
I'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER MANY
TIMES, I NEVER SAW ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
THAT WOULD BE UNACCEPTABLE, BUT
WITH VERY CONCERNING TO ME, NOW
THEY ARE JUST COMING TO THE
BORDER.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
FUNDING, HUMANITARIAN AID HERE
AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT
CONGRESSWOMAN WAS HOLDING IT UP.
SHE VOTED AGAINST THIS AID.
IF SHE EVEN VOTED AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS VOTE IN THE HOUSE JUST
A LITTLE BIT BEFORE, SO I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHERE SHE STANDS WHENI
EVEN KNOW WHERE SHE STANDS WHENT
COMES TO THIS ISSUE, THAT'S WHAT
CONCERNS ME.